in this video we'll be explaining all
aaron's titan forms in attack on titan
we will grow through these forms
chronologically starting with his pure
titan and then moving towards more and
more powerful titans aaron was born in
shiganshina district where he lived with
his adopted sister mikasa and his
parents they lived a normal life until
one day out of nowhere colossal titan
appeared outside of wall maria aaron
witnessed in shock as number of pure
titans swarmed the city through
destroyed gates of the wall he rushed
back home only to find his mom unable to
move and was saved by hanes as he
watched one of the pure titans eat his
mom aaron along with mikasa and armin
were sent to a shelter for refugees from
walmarea soon after grisha arrived and
found aaron there grisha already decided
that he was going to transfer his titan
powers onto his son he took aaron to a
nearby forest and before aaron could
react he injected him with a titan serum
turning him into pure titan aaron's pure
titan form looked like a child due to
aaron being very young at that time it
was also much shorter than his current
titan form it was four meters tall with
short rugged hair and a jagged lipless
mouth that exposed his teeth in the
early parts of season one after
inheriting titan powers from his father
aaron was very inexperienced and
couldn't control his powers and actions
when transformed after the military
found out that aaron can transform into
a titan they cornered him along with
mikasa and armin and were ready to kill
them they were scared and demanded to
know if aaron was their enemy due to his
hazy memory aaron is unable to answer
their questions satisfactorily and they
fire a cannon at him and his friends at
that moment aaron instinctively grabs on
to armin and mikasa and bites his own
hand partially transforming into a titan
and blocking the cannonball with the
titan's hand his titan transformation
was incomplete due to the fact that it
was his second titan transformation in a
short period of time we could only see
the upper body of his titan with one arm
that stopped the cannonball but it was
still enough to save his friends during
aaron's trial it's decided that he would
join survey court as part of squad levi
they are later sent to an abandoned
castle that had formerly served as the
base of operations for the survey corps
while there he meets squad leader hang
zoe who starts working with him helping
him get a better grip on his titan
powers during one of the experiments
with his titan abilities aaron is
lowered into a well before being told to
transform into a titan however aaron is
unable to activate his titan abilities
later while drinking tea with the rest
of the squad and questioning his titan
abilities he drops a spoon when he goes
on to reach it he suddenly activates his
titan abilities triggering his titan
transformation and leaving everyone in
shock confused soldiers drew their
swords thinking aaron transformed in
order to attack them when the smoke
cleared it's revealed that only his
right arm that was reaching for the
spoon transformed meaning that aaron
also possessed the power to transform
only a certain part of his body aaron
then learns that a titan transformation
requires him to have a clear goal in
mind in addition to self-injury aaron's
attack titan form is the main reason
parody island stood any chance in battle
against titans and marlene warriors
attack titan's powers combined with
aaron's passion and desire to kill every
titan in existence started the chain of
events in which aaron and survey core
defeated many titan shifters and learned
the truth about the outside world during
the battle of trust aaron was eaten
alive by in titan and inside the stomach
of the titan he saw other fellow
recruits lying dead this site combined
with intense feelings of desperation and
his drive to exterminate all titans
awoke his ability to transform into his
titan form for the first time when aaron
first transformed he didn't have control
of his titan form he could see straight
away that the attack titan was stronger
than pure titans of similar size even
though aaron still couldn't use its full
potential as a result his titan's limbs
were broken several times while punching
other pure titans and he was also easily
overwhelmed by a relatively low number
of titans when they swarmed him at the
same time once aaron got control of the
attack titan however it was a completely
different story his strength increased
at one point allowing him to lift a
boulder that mikasa remarked would have
been impossible for even a human of
proportion size to do while facing the
female titan in the titan forest he was
forced to adopt a more tactical approach
to fighting as annie had more experience
as a shifter and was a better
hand-to-hand fighter his titan skills
were put to the ultimate test as he
faced off with the armored titan in
season 2. upon finding out that his
fists did little to no damage to reiner
he was forced to switch his fighting
style despite being the physically
weaker and less durable titan aaron's
new style of fighting which included
tackles and holds would have eventually
led to reiner's defeat had the colossal
titan not interfered during his
experiments with hanji and the survey
corps aaron tried several times to
replicate the titan-heartening ability
annie had shown during their fight they
believed it could be the answer to
plugging the hole in shiganshina but
aaron didn't have any luck recreating
the crystal later during the battle at
rhys chapel after drinking a bottle
labeled armor aaron's titan form gained
the ability to harden its body as well
as create a web of pillars that appear
to originate from his titan body the
hardened pillars were incredibly durable
capable of preventing a cave-in as well
as shielding squad levi from the heat of
rodris's titan form aaron later mastered
hardening as we could see him focus his
ability only on his fists while fighting
against reiner's armor titan in
shiganshina when survey court launched a
retaliation attack on marley aaron
transformed into his attack titan form
multiple times showing that he now has
full control over his titan
transformations and abilities aaron also
shows an even greater aptitude for
battle applying all the titan fighting
techniques he's learned so far and using
his opponents against each other in
ingenious ways aaron obtained the power
of the warhammer titan during the raid
on liberio by devouring the younger
sister of willy upon returning to parody
island he was imprisoned for his
insubordination using his new warhammer
titan powers he manages to escape his
prison cell and was capable of sealing a
long tunnel with hardened titan flesh to
evade capture later while being on the
roof with peak eren spots a fleet of
marlin airships approaching their
location aaron is perplexed at marley's
decision to launch a counter-attack so
soon after the raid on liberio despite
yelena pleading with him to flee ground
aaron decides to fight marley on his own
he sees reiner transform into his armor
titan form mid air and decides to engage
him aaron initially gains the upper hand
on reiner using his fighting skills and
hardening to break through runner's
armor plating galliard in his jaw titan
form tries to ambush aaron from behind
but both he and reiner get caught and
pierced by aaron's warhammer spikes
aaron is shot in head with a round from
marley's anti-titan artillery leaving
his motor skills severely impaired aaron
is able to generate even more spikes to
stop the jaw titan's attacks unable to
defend from brainerd's attack aaron
finally manages to use his warhammer
abilities once more stopping both reiner
and galliard again warhammer titan's
abilities provided aaron with one thing
he was lacking strong defensive powers
it's clear that with the addition of
these new moves aaron became the most
powerful titan shifter excluding the
colossal titan and could battle against
multiple opponents at the same time
aaron's founding titan was drastically
different from yamir fritz's founding
titan and any other titan for that
matter initially much of the titan was
shrouded by the steam from the wall
titans but its sheer size was
immediately noted towering over the
horde of wall titans what appeared to be
the torso was devoid of flesh resembling
an enormous rib cage the head was the
only part of the body with much flesh
although it was significantly deformed
inside the titan aaron's head was
disconnected from his torso having been
decapitated and rejoined by yamir's
power the titan walked with its rib cage
undulating the ribs like a millipede's
legs aaron's founding titan had many
abilities he awakened and controlled
thousands of colossal titans in order to
destroy the entire world beyond parody
island since the founding titans are the
central point of intersection for the
paths of titans and humans alike it
could communicate with all of them
telepathically we saw how aaron used
this power to inform all the subjects of
emir about the decision to destroy the
world using the rumbling he also had the
ability to summon all the past titan
shifters back to life and controlled
them in order to fight against survey
court and marley warriors what makes
aaron different is that he had the power
to take the titan abilities away from
his friends so that they wouldn't be
able to stop him but he chose not to
giving humanity a chance to fight back
during the battle of heaven and earth
after soldiers finally managed to
destroy aaron's founding titan nape
everyone thought that the battle was
finally over sudden explosions out of
nowhere caught them off guard as aaron
emerges in his new colossal titan form
he still had his founding titan form
head therefore we can assume that he
created his colossal form out of his
founding titan nape his colossal titan
was the same height as armin's titan but
when they engaged in battle we could see
something fairly unusual aaron was able
to harden his titan's fists even in his
colossal titan form which was pretty
surprising since no other known user of
his power could do that aaron easily
gained the upper hand on armin and broke
his titan skull this is only my personal
opinion but i think that out of all
colossal titans we saw on the show aaron
is by far the strongest one he may even
be the strongest colossal titan that
ever existed click on this video where
we explained all jaw titans in attack on
titan